okay thank you it's a it's a pleasure to
be here what I'm going to talk about is
going to be a lot simpler than what Jeff
was going through we'll have a little
bit of preliminary hopefully book that
will introduce what Marty is is up to
they just have a couple of insights that
I'd like to portray and and can ask me
to talk about the value of information
in the calculations of such things with
reference to climate sensitivity so
here's among the things that I'm going
to try to convince you of if you're
thinking about the value of information
for things like climate sensitivity or
other manifestations of climate change
strikes me that it's the answer to how
to do it is it depends the answer to
every economic question is how it is
that it depends in this case I think it
depends on what decisions are going to
be made about what for whom under
conditions of uncertainty with what
different types of criteria the
decisions are being considered what is
the decision space that's offered to the
decision-maker to frame the approach to
the conversations he or she has to have
with him or herself and staff to try to
figure out what to do the range of
possible states of nature if they can be
probabilistically demonstrated and
represented fine if not think in a
systematic way about what it is you are
moving forward the prior is the
subjective priors that decision makers
have coming into their conversations
matter their attitudes towards risks
matter the timing of the decision
matters and the character code the
decision matters by the way before I get
too far can when you it your
interpretation of that gray area of the
range of the climate sensitivity and the
fifth assessment report you correctly
identified that they used their
uncertainty language but they did not
mean that the
66 to a hundred percent chance that the
climate said city estimates is in that
range it was more of this is the
interquartile range or something like
that they make people they screw that
sort of stuff up all of it okay so
potential criteria for simple-minded
approaches to this economic values
expected values but the tails are
important risk-based metrics if you want
to include some degree of aversion to
risk you could calculate certainty
equivalents that's sort of what Stern
did in a very elaborate way you can
think about thresholds on reality based
policy makers decision makers social
norms that seemed to reflect what people
want to do but it's important to notice
that these metrics depend on timing and
aversion to risk and the conversations
usually you know especially with things
like climate sensitive at climate policy
is mitigation but there's also
adaptation going on and information
about climate sensitivity can influence
those decisions as well here's some
preliminary examples of the sorts of
approaches that began the most recent
bills new book reflecting approaches to
uncertainty man and rituals began a good
deal of the conversation about hedging
and generated the notion that you can
either learn and then act or act and
learn and the fundamental result from
the fourth assessment report for my
money is that approaching policy
decisions in the climate arena has to
involve an iterative risk management
approach it makes it messier because
you're not generating internally
consistent necessarily economic
conclusions or trajectories for long
periods of time what you're doing is is
taking into the note and nobody's going
to write climate policy for the next
hundred years this year you'll do it
iteratively and make some liquor store
Corrections
and that makes the the problem and the
questions in the approach is a little
bit different I BCC wrote that 2007 in
the synthesis report the National
Research Council adopted it in America's
climate choices the National Climate
Assessment as adopt that perspective so
from that perspective what are the
fundamental sources of uncertainty on
the mitigation side this is a set of
graphs and figures from the
stabilization Committee of the National
Research Council that was chaired by
Susan Solomon they approach to the
iterative risk management on the
mitigation side has to do with
cumulative emissions over medium time
periods that are medium long not a
hundred years but 30 or 40 years they
are informed by the notion that one of
the fundamental drivers of global mean
temperature over the long term is
cumulative emissions from the beginning
until when they sort of disappear into
the from the emissions flow this
uncertainty graph is a little bit
different than usual it says long-run
equilibrium global made temperature
change and estimates of the cumulative
emissions over the long term that would
support those in the uncertainty bear of
bounds there give you an idea of the
uncertainty around which you have to
frame the conversation what are the
interim cumulative emissions targets for
an iterative risk-based approach to that
I did a little bit of that sort of work
a while ago with Michaels schlessinger
fundamentally what we observed is that
shooting for one temperature target in
the context of a variety of different
climate sensitivities from a degree and
a half up to 9 degrees centigrade had
the potential of closing doors so that
you couldn't get there so if you were
shooting at 3 degrees and suddenly feel
found out you wanted to go to 2
even if you started right away you
wouldn't be able to get there for some
of these circumstances but if you don't
do anything through 2020 35 you close
more doors than that that is a value of
information not calibrated and currency
but it gives you an idea of what the
tales that you might want to worry about
could look like here is the lesser the
graph that comes out of energy modeling
form 20-something 26 22 whatever but it
was it picked up by the limiting panel
of America's climate choices and so this
calculation was okay between now and
2050 let's behave as if we want to go to
550 parts per million what are the
cumulative emissions that would be
consistent for that for the globe and
what is the u.s. share of those budgets
and it was either somewhere between 170
and 200 gig and tons and certain
emissions co2 equivalents over that 40
year time period the notion then is some
time before 2050 this calculation in
consideration is redone reflections of
the risk associated with further warming
is redone on the basis of new
information about climate sensitivity
and the potential that new information
could tell you a little bit more about
whether the tail is thick or how big it
is or what's going on as well as what
the damages look like what the
transients look like how well countries
are participating in emissions
trajectories and so on so in that world
the value of information about climate
sensitivity is the value of being able
to morph oral formally understand what
the mid-course correction might look
like and identify the pace at which you
should be making the observations on
climate sensitivity and hopefully the
learning pattern so that you can
announce what's going to be the
mid-course correction in enough time
that it's not a sudden surprise to
anybody
I can do this one I I'm in front of
Marty Marty's it has been a spectacular
contributor to lots and lots of stuff
across economics and fundamentally what
he does is take really really really
complicated problems and dilute them
down to their most fundamental nature so
that you can work the problem generate
some insight from that that is perfectly
generalizable and informs enormous
amounts of work in the complex world
that he simplified so I've got a simple
model to suggest this value of
information in the sensitivity with
respect to priors and things it's just a
little simple decision tree two possible
States of nature to adaptations to
actions and the subjective probabilities
that decision makers will undertake are
informed by the information that I come
in with so where does climate
sensitivity come in it might ask you or
to cause you to change the subjective
priors that you enter the observation is
that if you use these particular
concepts and do a little bit of
arithmetic what you can get our ranges
of ambiguity of the decision that you
will undertake depending on the on the
decision rule that you're using expected
outcome or certainty equivalence no big
news there but you also can compute the
value of information according to those
specific approaches and the value of
information depends on the subjective
prior that people come in with so the
value of information itself could change
as we learn more about distributions of
things like climate sensitivity not only
because the prior changes and so these
calculations are doing change but also
the decision that you take might
actually be different
the last bit I wanted to talk about a
nano said a little bit about it in that
that iterative bit through 2050 but
there's also the notion that the timing
of decisions can be informed by the way
in which you look at how the uncertainty
will unfold there are as Jeff said a lot
of climate impacts for which the local
regional sub-continental uncertainty
span 0 causes some degree of difficulty
there is and the notion for example of
large coastal storms and hurricanes and
then the questions what have we detected
and attributed of changes in the
intensity and frequency of those storms
to human-induced climate change and that
argument continues to rage but there are
things that we know a little bit more
about and that is the implications of
sea level rise on damages associated
with all kinds of storms not just the
fat tails and you could begin to think
about an adaptation project that might
be very expensive to protect yourself
from most of the tails of the
distribution depending on how it evolves
over time so this is a paper it's been
awhile now that i did with paul kirshen
and kathy knee looked at whether
distribution patterns historical records
for an urban area in boston for which
somebody had already done the
calculation of what an adaptation
protection barrier would cost we then
had distributions associated with those
weather events on economic cost and you
can move them forward simply by changing
sea level rise in the manifestation of a
25-year storm that might be the 25 year
storm in today's world ends up looking
like the 50 or 75 year storm in today's
world
15 or 20 or 30 or 40 years from now do
all of that you can make some
calculations of internal rate of return
based either on people who are
risk-averse or people who are not and
the risk-neutral and you can calculate
how those trajectories of calculations
of internal rate of return change over
time to get an idea of when you might
want to undertake the investment in this
protection project if you use a four
percent cutoff rate for your decision
along a 6 60 centimeter sea level rise
trajectory it looks like long about 2040
it might be a good time to do it but
along a hundred centimeter sea level
rise trajectory it looks a lot like you
better do it somewhere around twenty
twenty or twenty twenty-five what would
be the value of improved information on
climate sensitivity that would allow you
to make adjustments on your subjective
view of whether it's more likely that
we're going to be 60 centimeters or a
hundred centimeters is relatively
critical in the timing that's imposed
and suggested here that it would be
really nice if we had that information
in the next 10 or 15 years for at least
that decision works out now that's not a
ubiquitous decision the numbers are
specific to the place but that's the
sort of conceptual visualization of
value information that isn't based on
the numerical calculations the one thing
the one last thing I want to put up as
as a thing for conversation is how do
how I'm going to be much shorter than
that how do we think about communicating
what we know and what we don't know in a
way that is consistent with the
complexity that Jeff was talking about
the catastrophes that mario is going to
be talking about and the uncertainties
and the fundamental uncertainties that
are just going to take an enormous
amount of time to resolve so one
question that has been in the back of my
mind for a couple of years now and I
actually after I figured out how to say
it like this found out that Steve
Schneider said it like this a long time
ago but the notion is you have to tell
the truth and you have to tell nothing
but the truth but you have to tell the
whole truth don't know thank you